[Aplausos]
um dia todos conseguem ouvir o meu
batimento cardíaco 3 fato é que está
sendo que nenhum alterado é mãe é quem
têm entre 19 e 39 anos
ok temos aqui uma grande parte da
audiência é nós somos e que o qq no
marketing
hoje em dia chamamos os milênios
contendo um carinho da minha história
estou mal da iac muito próximas o dobro
ruim neste ano em 86 o ano de entrada de
portugal na cee e isso me léo como como
vocês tudo de uma família tradicional em
que sim mas foi impedido que nós víamos
a respeitar os outros claro viver em
comunidade
mas também devemos seguir as regras dos
outros portanto nunca ninguém dentro de
casa ele se crie o vosso próprio negócio
vão aventura pensa em podem construir
alguma coisa sozinhos
amo a minha avó e costura jornal da ilha
pelo menos uma das minhas avós e então
sempre foi incutido queremos entrar numa
empresa mantendo uma boa posição social
ter uma boa casa cumprir as regras
trabalhar das novas sanções mas que
manteria assim que nós éramos instrui
durante nossa nosso crescimento
sua neta mais velha de 10 sua primeira
licenciar se equivoque o as
oportunidades que a minha mãe não tendo
minha mãe sempre história infelizmente
não foi possível
é então eu aos 13 anos seria eu vou ser
porta guerra
portanto eu vou estar na minha cidade
minha é isso que eu quero
a segunda parte é verdade espero não
estar em mim mas não sou repórter de
guerra que felizmente com menos em juízo
como diz a minha mãe é e nunca me
encontrei o marketing digital e já na
universidade encontra isso que eu acho
que é o meu caminho e tudo o que você
vai falar também não terem ainda neste
caminho de ser produtor de the
respeitadas empresas de seguir o que os
outros união é um objetivo era eu vou
trabalhar numa grande empresa portanto
eu vou ter 6 quando consiste em criar
uma equipa quando eu conseguir ter uma
posição importante empresas canadá
chegaram diretores onde diretor de uma
das áreas da empresa
entre vários projetos onde escondeu mais
prazer foi fazer parte da equipa da
salsa objeto brilhante e que até hoje me
sinto muito contente por ter passado por
lá um rico começou a dar aulas e começa
a perceber que eu tenho um carinho mais
do que só a trabalhar numa empresa e
estou disposta ela passar mais tempo
fora
está gostoso ensinar a fazer oq project
mas se pensar criar isso uma marca
talvez eu possa começar a ter traçar
este caminho
no entanto que só estava por trás já vem
de uma família em que os pais
denunciaram passamos algumas circulações
financeiras nunca na vida eu ia ficar
sozinhas ao que eu pra mim arian y em
2014 surgiu o convite para ir para onde
vai
a espetacular um feito espetacular vou
conhecer uma cultura completamente
diferente da história a gente por trás
da minha família casa antes de ir eu só
estou completamente louca eu não há
problema nenhum podem dizer o começo o
que era o meu grande sonho trabalhar
numa grande empresa criar uma estrutura
de um futuro e foi o pior ano da minha
vida foi um ano extremamente complicado
foi um ano que eu percebia caiu afinal
não é isso que eu quero eu quero ter uma
marca quer ser e vou criar a minha marca
a cheia de medo completamente cheia
uma amiga minha que eu tenho a
oportunidade será que eu vou ter alguns
passos no mercado e sempre que o total
para passar para ensinado neste neste
último ano em maio que o tempo
trabalhado com muitas empresas
na zona do norte é principalmente na
zona norte e e tenha percebido esta
dualidade entre o que é uma marca e que
quer ser um produtor de vinho durante
muito tempo sabe que eu era um produtor
eu comprei as regras eu entregava rápido
fazer bem as coisas mas eu tenho muito
pouca voz e achava que o marketing
digital e comércio poderia fazer com que
estas marcas que oferecem esses eram
destaque por nomes muito facilmente
nós pensávamos que aqui na nossa área
geográfica temos pequenas confecções eu
produzi pijamas e 30 cêntimos e que as
marcas vão vender 30 euros
nós estamos a perceber a diferença que
existe o gap que existem de ser um
produtor ser uma marca
aí os produtores são os trolhas as
marcas são os arquitetos as marcas
realmente marcos e nós portugueses somos
ótimos na produção
somos muito bons estamos rápidas são
mensagens temos um custo de produção
qualidade muito muito bom
somos ótimos lá fora mas pois são as
marcas que leva o nosso lá por fora as
suas marcas que fazem mexer é que o
marketing digital e-commerce
na minha opinião são os pontos podem
mais ajudar os nossos produtores de
criarem marcas e ganharem esta voz cair
as feiras internacionais a exportar a
ter uma visão global do mundo existem
imensas empresas em portugal que estão
no mercado há 20 30 40 50 anos mas que
não vão passar produtores porque as
gerações mais novas que estão a pensar
nelas agora continuam a pensar como
antigamente a pensar que nós temos é que
ser muito bons a fazer isto
temos muito organizadinho sem entregar
na altura certa e aqui que nós temos que
nos posicionar nós mil e mails não é
isso que nós queremos nós queremos
marcar o mundo nós queremos deixar o
lugar comum e é isso que eu quero é por
isso que eu dou aos apps que eu ensino
porque eu sei que não é possível
existirem várias mais no país nem sequer
acho que vou conseguir fazer todos os
projetos de e commerce que existem no
país nos próximos anos serão muito bons
nesta área nos próximos anos vamos ver
muitas marcas a crescer e este analisar
se exportar
a voz no mundo a partir do e camas
por isso é que eu acredito que ao
ensinar as empresas com as quais eu
trabalho nas aulas que hollande
conseguiu fazer com que o meu lugar
ficou com que as pessoas criam chão e
com que as marcas criação das marcas com
as quais nós mais nos identificamos
trará que toda a gente o facebook hoje
sim alguém já usou o google maps para
chegar aqui hoje cai a quem tem um
iphone
todas estas marcas com as quais nós
lidamos no dia a dia são marcas que nos
dá ferramentas pra eu tomar as minhas
decisões são marcas como joão a pensar
mas que não criam barreiras não diz aí
tem que ser assim tem que pensar desta
forma a pesquisa desta forma eu possa
personalizar o meu telemóvel com os atos
que eu quiser e esta é a minha visão do
mundo é que nós devemos ajudar é que as
marcas criação e que elas consigam
implementar e que ela consiga ganhar uma
voz e uma visão como podemos fazer isso
todo o meu exemplo prático
em primeiro lugar eu tenho um
posicionamento no mercado que o martim
qualquer pessoa de martinho prêmio nos
primeiros anos da popular que é o
posicionamento como é que um posiciona
no mercado
eu trabalho com as empresas para ajudar
a fazer crescer o negócio encontrei meu
nicho de mercado que o e-commerce e
marketing digital para para e commerce e
tenho meu público alvo muito muito bem
identificado eu sei quais são as
empresas que têm potencial para o cheiro
sei quais são as empresas que fazem
sentido para mim depois é o trabalho que
existe um traço temos tecnologia que
funciona temos três equipas certas ea
pensar o marketing digital não é de
borla
quem vencer está enganado quem tem que
ter investimento temos que estar contigo
continuamente amizade e se pensarmos que
fez uma coisa assim amanhã é só nós tem
que estar muito atentos ao marcar muito
capaz de evoluir e fazer crescer as
nossas marcas a partir daqui também por
outro lado é muito fácil de estado o
investimento que nós precisávamos há 20
anos atrás por uma marca no mercado
inferior hoje em dia nós conseguimos
testar facilmente coisas no reino unido
em frança estivesse mercado aceitar o
produtor não e depois começar a fazer é
envio ou instituições
a série preços preços mercados
em suma a minha visão do mundo é esta eu
quero deixar um gato
eu quero que daqui a 50 anos
as empresas em portugal que estejam a
chery que continue a crescer a partir
das vendas online cai consigam dizer a
velha teve um efeito qualquer um na
minha vida
o dobro das idéias que vera tinha
naquela altura teve um efeito qualquer a
mim não me interessa se é apenas um
produtor se eu quero ficar na cabeça das
pessoas
eu quero ser uma marca é isso que me
move todos os dias quando aulas quando
estou aqui com vocês e eu deixo vos
então esta pergunta que eu acho que é
perguntar como faz mais sentido
vocês querem ser produtores não querem
ser marcas
vocês querem influenciar a vida dos
outros no trabalho em casa na educação
que são as vossas filhos nas empresas
que criam na forma como até vendem as
nossas empresas
vocês querem continuar a produzir fazer
as coisas direitinho sem entregar a
tempo a fazer chegar e estar até podem
ter um pegar e aporta no final do mês
vocês podem ter a ferrari um porsche mas
será que é isso que realmente vos faz a
diferença e mostrar que vocês querem ser
marcas e quero marcar a vida das pessoas
tudo piano na minha opinião da forma
como vocês querem seguir a nossa vida
sejam marcas não sejam produtores
muito obrigado
[Aplausos]